so in the aftermath of this particular
shooting
in colorado and remember this comes in
the aftermath of this shoot at this
awful shooting in atlanta where a white
guy
shot eight people including six asian
americans and the media immediately
without any evidence declared this as
evidence of broader trumpian white
supremacy
again evidence that this is a hate crime
still completely absent in that
particular case
maybe it'll be found have been found yet
you'd figure
you probably have found it by now if you
were looking for it but
the media immediately jumped to the
conclusion after the colorado shooting
the identity of the shooter was not
immediately released to the media
now there's a pattern in the media and
the pattern in the media tends to be
that when the shooter is white this is
why conservatives held off on this
when the pattern when the shooter is
white the identity is immediately
released to the media generally
almost almost immediately like within a
couple of hours because
once the guy's in custody he got the guy
in custody so then it's just a question
of when
the police decide to reveal the identity
of the person in custody when the person
is non-white
not only will the police wait on
actually breaking the news the media
will then downplay exactly
the race or ethnicity of the person
because again all this plays into
broader narratives about what the
country should do
now with regard to things like
immigration or things like race god
forbid but what the country should do
with regard to things like more policing
what sort of measures should be taken
but for the left because every problem
in america can be attributed to quote
unquote white supremacy and whiteness
they immediately jumped into the story
and got the story completely wrong
you have to understand that for the left
right now whiteness is what atheists say
about
religious people they call it the god of
the gaps so atheists will frequently say
about religious people
that religious people can't prove god
they can't prove that god exists so what
they'll do
is they'll look at the universe and then
if there's something unexplained they'll
say ah god
right so quantum mechanics happens and
it completely throws off
some einsteinian einsteinian theories
about how the universe works and
religious believers go ah god
and atheists will say no that's not god
you just don't understand how that works
and
god doesn't necessarily fill in that gap
right that's the god of the gaps okay
well
for the left they have whiteness and
white supremacy of the gaps
if there is a story they don't like they
just explain it with regards to
whiteness
we saw this with regard to
discrimination against asian americans
right if black americans are beating up
asian americans in disproportionate
numbers that is because of white
supremacy and america's systems of power
if asian americans are succeeding too
well in the system that's because asian
americans are buying into systems of
white supremacy and if white people are
targeting asian
asian americans that's also because of
white supremacy so no matter what the
grand unifying field theory of american
politics for the left is white supremacy
so they tried to apply this without
evidence
to the colorado shooting this was their
immediate jump they immediately jumped
into
this was a white guy because there was a
picture released and the guy looked
white
well turns out the guy's not white the
guy's actually syrian okay and it turns
out that mass shooters are not always
white in fact according to statista
of the 120 or so mass shootings in the
united states between 1982
and march 2021 about half of them are
done by white people
but the other half are not done by white
people
which is roughly the racial distribution
of the united states generally
and so that myth is just not true in the
first place that all mass shooters are
white
okay that is something that is
promulgated by the media because the
media wishes to suggest
that white people present the white
people with guns present the true threat
to the united states and blue check
marks jumped into this
immediately right they started jumping
into this like
right away they started tweeting out
over and over and over that the shooter
was white and this just demonstrates
that america's a white supremacist
country and also
because the police arrested this guy
after wounding him as opposed to just
shooting him dead
that's because they liked him the police
were racist
it doesn't matter that cop was actually
shot to death by the guy the police were
racist because they liked the white guy
but they never take the black guy alive
which is just a lie it is just overtly
untrue
okay but you have some commentate some
blue check julie dicaro who wrote
extremely tired of people's lives
depending on whether a white man with an
ar15
is having a good day or not right you
have
alex cole tweeting out a white man
walked into a grocery store in boulder
not true
killed 10 people and was apprehended by
the police and walked out of the
building completely unharmed
right down the street police killed
elijah mclean while he apologized for
not doing
anything wrong okay again untrue
they thought that he was they thought
that they had to give him a drug because
he was responding
uh in in incoherent ways to their to
their commands
it may in fact be a homicide case i
believe it's being brought as a homicide
case right now
but what these two things have to do
with each other the answer is nothing
rasheed esquire another blue check he
tweeted out
beyond infuriating that the colorado
terrorists killed a cop but was arrested
alive while cops shot tamir rice dead
for holding a toy because the cop feared
for his life how's an unarmed black
child more frightening than a grown
white male mass murderer
reckless i don't understand were you
there
did did like wha what
okay so this is just the narrative that
builds up every time right when when the
shooter in charleston
was of the black church right the racist
terrorist who shot up the black church
when he did that he was arrested and the
narrative was look at how the police are
treating him so nicely
well the police tried to arrest a lot of
people without killing them
if the police killed everybody who
presented a general threat to the public
there'd be a lot more dead people in the
united states
of all races but that doesn't that
doesn't matter the narrative has to be
promulgated the narrative is always
again
white supremacy is the answer even if
it's clearly not white supremacy as
we'll see in a second michael harriott
of the root who's just awful
he tweeted out pointing out how white
suspects get the benefit of the doubt
without being stopped first beaten shot
or killed
is not a call for harsh treatment it
simply means we know cops are
capable of treating people humanely just
not us y'all could use a few more ass
whoopings though
he's just a bad person i'm sorry just a
bad person first of all
there is tape of white people being beat
to death
by police officers unjustifiably or shot
unjustifiably by the police
in fact there are studies done it says
that
actually police tend to
disproportionately shoot white suspects
in dangerous situations as opposed to
black suspects
in situations and that does not matter
apparently at all not only does that not
matter it does not matter that the
suspect in this case
was not white the suspect kamala
harris's niece tweeted out about this
and actually had to delete
her own tweet about the white shooter
she tweeted out the atlanta shooting was
not even a week ago
violent white men are the greatest
terrorist threat to our country
violent white man are the greatest
terrorist threat to our country and then
she tweeted out i deleted a previous
tweet about the suspect in the boulder
shooting i made an assumption based on
his being taken into custody alive
and the fact that the majority of mass
shootings in the united states are
carried out by white men
okay so in other words you made an
assumption about some
shooting based on general racial
statistics
interesting interesting you should do
that
if you're on the left you can get away
with anything
anything by the way solid apology right
there that is not even an apology that's
like well you know i made an assumption
first of all
you know what the majority of people who
live in this country are white which
means that for virtually any stat you
can choose the majority of people who do
it
are white okay like so
the majority of people who eat hot dogs
in the united states are white
so i saw a guy eating a hot dog what
color was he well he's probably white
because
like wha what what what are you even
talking about it's statistical
statistical incompetence okay so as it
turns out
all of this immediately fell apart
because unfortunately for the left-wing
narrative about how whiteness is the
greatest threat
to america this particular gunman
happened not to be
white he was a syrian born person and
not only that
he ranted about islamophobes hacking his
phone he was apparently suffering
from mental illness the person's brother
told the daily beast he was very
antisocial and has been paranoid since
high school
the brother describes him as mentally
ill said he'd been bullied in school and
was not politically motivated
his sister-in-law said she'd seen him
playing with a gun recently but did not
suspect him of violence
and also he tweeted out a bunch of stuff
that was kind of supportive of isis over
the past
few years he tweeted out about how trump
was terrible
i mean this this seems like a mentally
ill person
hey and rant he ranted about trump he
rants about refugees
he happens to be have been a muslim
although we don't know that islam was
actually the motivation in the shooting
looks more like mental illness but in
any case this does not comport with the
fact pattern that the left would like to
promulgate
but that does not matter and the left
never acknowledges its own hypocrisy on
this score ilhan omar had just the best
set of tweets on this so illidan omar
tweeted out two things right so a week
ago
after the atlanta shooting ellen omar
tweeted out it isn't hard to understand
why it's so normalized for law
enforcement to protect the humanity of
white mass murderers and their
willingness to continually make excuses
for them
and then like a week later ellen omar
tweeted out the shooter's race or
ethnicity seems front and center when
they aren't white
otherwise it's just a mentally ill young
man having a bad day narratives drive
our responses to awful crimes committed
against innocent people pay attention to
these responses and who is targeted
literally a week ago she was targeting
you know the atlanta shooting as race
based
and talking about the race of the
shooter now you can't mention the race
of the shooter because if you do
then you're targeting people based on
race it's
unreal so notice something here okay
notice
that when the left uses racism as a
charge or when they bring up
white supremacy as a charge all of this
seems to be politically motivated
pretty much all of it it is it is a tool
they can charge their opponents with
racism and then be as racist as they
could
possibly want to be even if the evidence
doesn't back the position this is twice
in the course of two weeks that the left
got the narrative completely wrong and
it's still going to be rammed down
america's throat
in atlanta the narrative was that it was
white supremacy that was behind the
shooting and that was connected to trump
and the wuhan virus and all of this kind
of stuff and it wasn't true there's no
evidence of it and then
the entire media jumped on the idea that
this guy was treated in colorado with
kid gloves because he was white and it
turns out he wasn't even white
again it's all about power whatever is
the brickbat at hand you have to use it
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button